[Musique]
le
tous je m'appelle bus et je suis
illusionniste alors j'ai découvert la
magie à 10 ans en rencontrant un mec qui
faisait apparaître ces cartes exactement
comme ça et en fait ça m'a rendu
complètement dingue
au début ça m'a fasciné puis après ça
m'a torture est ce que je voulais
absolument apprendre comment il fait
alors cette même personne m'a expliqué
comment ça fonctionnait et au moment où
il m'a raconté ce qui se passait devant
derrière sa main de tous les côtés j'ai
trouvé ça encore plus magique en fait
parce que je savais que physiquement
c'était impossible pour moi de le
réaliser
évidemment je vais travailler jour et
nuit quand j'étais à votre place en
école de commerce je travaillais sur mon
bureau en cours de marketing aux
finances et au bout d'un moment ça a
fonctionné
évidemment le jour où ça fonctionne et
je devenu insupportable dès que je
croise quelqu'un organes j'ai appris un
truc je le faisais absolument tout le
monde ça servait à rien mais ça me
faisait plaisir
alors pourquoi je vous raconte ça c'est
vrai que savoir que j'ai musclé la
troisième phalange de mon index pour
faire apparaître un domino de cartes ça
tout le monde s'en fout et par contre
prendre conscience que quelque chose qui
était physiquement impossible pour moi
est devenu possible ça je trouve ça
extraordinaire et en fait c'est un petit
peu ce qu'on fait en magie c'est qu'on
passe notre temps à réfléchir à des
idées ou des mises en scène qui nous
paraissent impossibles pour les rendre
possible donc en fait en magie on
transforme la réaliser alors à travers
cette conférence j'aimerais vous parler
un petit peu de cet état d'esprit et
vous invitez vous aussi essayer de
transformer votre réalité pour peut-être
réaliser des rêves ou des projets qui
vous paraissent inaccessibles dans des
projets ça peut être créer une
entreprise
une ambition artistique ouvrir une
pâtisserie ce que vous voulez la seule
chose c'est qu'au moment où je vous
parle on est en plein troisième
confinement donc si votre projet c'est
d'ouvrir un resto c'est pas vraiment le
bon timing
alors j'ai bien conscience que je n'ai
aucune leçon à donner à personne mais si
je suis devant vous aujourd'hui c'est
bon déjà c'est parce qu'on me l'a
demandé mais aussi c'est parce qu'il ya
dix ans je rêvais de devenir magicien et
faire des spectacles et aujourd'hui
c'est devenu mon métier
donc j'aimerais vous partager 5 trucs
qui m'ont aidé à réaliser ce projet pour
moi la première chose le point de départ
de tout ça c'est cette photo en fait
c'est super important de prendre
conscience qu'il faut il faut absolument
décomposer son rêve en petites étapes
accessible par exemple dans mon cas mon
rêve était de faire un spectacle donc on
va imaginer que le nuage représente le
fait d'avoir mon spectacle à paris alors
le premier barreau de cette échelle avec
plein de petits barreaux c'était d'aller
voir mes parents et leurs ex
cliquez qu'après cinq années d'école de
commerce je voulais tu magicien alors ça
a été très rapide ça a pris cinq minutes
évidemment aucun soucis avec mes parents
deuxième bar ou un petit peu plus
compliqué deuxième étape il fallait que
je trouve un restaurant pour travailler
au pourboire
parce qu'en fait on imagine le meilleur
moyen de progresser c'est de faire un
maximum de magie un maximum de gens donc
évidemment travailler pour part dans ses
restaurants ça permet de rencontrer
plein de gens c'est comme ça que j'ai
décidé de devenir magicien saisonnier
donc pendant trois ans j'ai travaillé
l'été à saint-tropez et l'hiver à val
d'isère
moi je mettais plutôt bien organisé
alors évidemment dans ce contexte on
rencontre plein de gens différents
il faut savoir que pour moi toutes les
tables ou même toutes les personnes à
qui j'ai fait de la magie qu'il soit
restaurateurs artistes ou président de
la république ou simplement vacanciers
chacune de ces personnes représentent un
petit baroud mon échelle qui m'ont
emmené jusqu'au projet de spectacle et
un jour l'une de ces étapes ce petit
barros et arthur qui a décidé de
produire mon spectacle est donc ça y est
on y est en trente secondes on est
arrivé sur mon petit nuage c'était mon
rêve à voir mon spectacle à paris ce qui
est marrant si vous regardez cette photo
c'est que le petit bonhomme de droite
lui il est complètement bloquée en bas
et en fait il peut pas avancer parce que
je pense que ce petit bonhomme à droite
il symbolise tous les gens qui veulent
absolument prendre des raccourcis et
faire des pas de géants alors que le
plus efficace pour se rapprocher de son
rêve c'est de fonctionner par petites
étapes accessible il ya autre chose peut
être que ce petit bonhomme à droite n'a
pas compris c'est qu'il faut accepter
attention deuxième photo de sortir de sa
zone de confort alors cette photo elle
est très simple à comprendre
world of magic happened c'est tout ce
qui peut nous arriver d'extraordinaire
dans la vie donc c'est tous vos projets
tous vos rêves dont on parlait tout à
l'heure
créer une entreprise écrire un album
monter un spectacle peu important de
projets tous à tous ces projets tous ses
rêves il se passe en dehors de notre
zone de confort on peut pas espérer
avoir des résultats différents dans nos
vies si on fait tous les jours les mêmes
choses ou les mêmes actions en fait ça
serait fou d'espérer qui nous arrive des
choses extraordinaires si depuis
toujours on a des habitudes qui sont
ordinaires alors il ya plein de manières
de sortir de sa zone de confort mais
pour moi la plus importante c'est de
rencontrer un maximum de gens en fait il
faut se débrouiller pour rencontrer tous
les gens qui peuvent potentiellement
nous aider dans nos projets et oser leur
parler
et leur raconter tout simplement ce qui
nous fait rêver parce que en fait on n'a
pas conscience de la quantité de gens
qui peuvent nous aider dans ce monde à
réaliser tous ses projets je me souviens
encore un exemple en école de commerce
on était très nombreux à vouloir créer
notre entreprise il ya un style
d'entrepreneurs que je trouve très
bizarre c'est que ce sont des gens qui
sont secrets et c'est pas des gens qui
sont secrets parce qu'ils ont trouvé
quelque chose qu'ils ont breveté que la
nasa a refusé qu'ils vous vendre à
quelqu'un d'autre
ils veulent absolument protéger leurs
idées de potentiels concurrents
le problème de cet état d'esprit c'est
que en voulant se protéger de potentiels
concurrents
on se protège de potentiels
investisseurs mais aussi de potentiels
clients
c'est pour ça que je suis convaincu
qu'il faut partager au maximum ses idées
et en plus ce qui est génial c'est que
plus on partage nos idées plus on
s'engage auprès d'interlocuteurs
différents et on sait pertinemment quand
on va revoir on va revoir ces mêmes
personnes
deux semaines plus tard ils vont nous
dire alors ça avance et on est si on est
pas sorti suffisamment notre zone de
confort on risque de les décevoir
on va passer à la troisième partie de
cette conférence donc troisième photo
avec moi ma conférence est très simple
ces 5 partis cinq photos on va pas se
faire de claquage
j'ai trouvé quelqu'un qui a pour moi le
meilleur état d'esprit du monde pour
partager ces projets lui alors s'il
fallait résumer cette photo je dirais
que nous sommes ce que nous pensons être
je sais plus qui a dit ça je sais même
pas si quelqu'un l'a dit mais ça
explique parfaitement ce que j'ai envie
de vous expliquer je vous laisse la
répéter une fois dans votre tête
nous sommes ce que nous pensons être oui
je suis convaincu que ce petit poisson
avec son costume il nage tranquillement
au milieu des requins et qui a aucun
problème
eh bien je pense qu'on devrait tous
inspirés de son comportement en termes
d'énergie pour partager nos projets par
exemple si j'arrive avec cette
conférence et que je suis surchargé en
énergie et j'arrivais vraiment vous
sentez que hyper excitée parce qu'il
faut que vous partagez un truc qui est
incroyable qui m'a aidé moi donc
peut-être ça va vous aider vous
normalement mon énergie est contagieuse
et vous aussi vous êtes un petit peu
excité bon là en l'occurrence ya
personne mais j'ai assez d'explications
pour les 500 sièges qui sont vite donc
ça c'est pas grave autre contexte
quand je travaillais au pourboire à
saint tropez par exemple donc il faut se
projeter un peu c'est le pire contexte
du monde pour faire de la magie c'est à
dire que les gens ne nous attendent pas
vous connaissent pas il ya de la musique
super fort donc on s'entend même pas
quand on discute on sait pas quelle
langue ils parlent et le pire
ils sont en train de manger
quoi qu'il arrive on les dérange et
pourtant je savais pertinemment que si
j'arrivais avec la bonne énergie
enthousiaste j'étais sûr d'embarquer la
table avec ma folie et puis ça pouvait
durer quinze minutes 30 minutes les gens
dont j'ai froid mais c'est pas grave on
passé un super moment ensemble
al'inverse si j'arrive à cette même
table mais ben je sais pas trop si j'ai
envie d'y aller je suis un peu gêné
j'y vais j'y vais pas eh ben ce même
sentiment devient contagieux donc je
suis gêné donc je devient gênant donc
ils n'acceptent pas la table donc pas de
magie pas de pourboire
pas de spectacle alors évidemment c'est
beaucoup plus facile pour un magicien
d'aborder les gens parce que le jeu de
cartes c'est un petit peu comme le
costume de ce poisson
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que les les
mécanismes de mimétisme humain il marche
quel que soit le contexte
si vous adresser à quelqu'un a voulu
partager quelque chose en souriant
sincèrement il ya 99% de chance qui
sourit
si vous voulez qu'on trouve votre projet
passionnant il faut absolument que vous
soyez passionné
c'est tellement bête mais moi je suis
convaincu que c'est la clé dans la
manière de partager son projet avec les
autres alors parfois on est passionné on
est dans le bon état d'esprit mais on
n'arrive pas à se débarrasser de la peur
alors le gros souci avec la peur c'est
que plus on a peur de quelque chose
plus on a de chances que ça arrive en
gros si vous avez peur d'échouer
vous êtes sûr d'échouer je vais vous les
payez avec un petit exemple très simple
imaginez vous voulez faire un salto
arrière en ski ou en snowboard
vous partez dans la descente à fond
évidemment parce que pendant un petit
instant vous avez la confiance
puis au fur et à mesure que la beauce se
rapproche vous avez peur vous freiner
encore plus pour freiner encore plus là
vous faites un tout petit saut 1/2 salto
et hop la tête dans la neige
c'est la même chose par exemple avant de
monter un spectacle
on en a tous un petit peu des petites
appréhensions on a peur et moi ma petite
routine avant de monter sur scène c'est
d'essayer de transformer cette peur en
excitation ou en adrénaline
alors c'est facile à dire mais il ya des
techniques moi par exemple ce que j'aime
faire c'est de de remixer un petit peu
mes pensées si par exemple je regardais
le rideau jeudi mais tous ces gens mais
ça me stresse je sais même plus ce que
je vais leur dire cela c'est la
catastrophe
il va plutôt de penser ça je pense à ces
mêmes personnes mais dans un autre
contexte
je me dis il ya une demi heure on est en
plein hiver ils ont mis leurs gros
manteau ils sont partis dans leur
voiture comme ça en famille ils sont
venus ici pour faire la teuf avec moi en
fait ça peut que bien se passer
voilà c'est une petite gymnastique à
faire dans son cerveau même si
évidemment
le plus important et ça c'est vraiment
bateau mais c'est pourtant la vérité
c'est l'entraînement où le travail comme
on aime dire à l'école plus on a
entraîné moins on a de chances de se
faire abîmée par la peur mais il arrive
parfois que la peur persiste et qu'on
n'arrive vraiment pas à s'en débarrasser
pour ça je vais vous proposer une une
autre technique qui ressemble un petit
peu une manipulation qu'on peut utiliser
en magie l'idée c'est d'essayer de
tromper ou ont mystifié son cerveau donc
reprenons l'exemple classique d'école de
commerce vous devez pitch est votre
projet à un investisseur potentiel et
que vous savez que cette personne peut
changer votre vie ça c'est un contexte
insupportable parce que vous savez très
bien que vous savez pitcher votre votre
projet vous l'avait raconté dix mille
fois vous l'avez raconter à vos familles
et à vos proches aux gens du métier
c'est factuel
vous savez le faire mais ce jour-là pour
je ne sais quelle raison parce que cette
personne est si spécial pour vous votre
corps à la capacité de s'auto sa beauté
et ça c'est insupportable
alors il ya une phrase parfaite pour ces
contextes qui dit fake it until you make
it moi je propose un petit remix en
français pour moi si on a peur ou si on
manque de confiance en soi il faut
réussir à se conditionner pour créer
l'illusion de la confiance en nous alors
évidemment c'est à prendre comme un jeu
mais je peux vous assurer que si vous
jouez sincèrement cette illusion de
confiance devient réel et vous finissez
par vraiment avoir confiance en vous
donc j'ai un exemple d'un jour où j'ai
utilisé cette technique c'est à l'époque
où je travaillais à saint tropez
je reçois un coup de fil et on me
demande de venir faire un spectacle pour
très peu de personnes sur un bateau et
on dit attention habille toi bien après
par des bons trucs parce que c'est
quelqu'un de c'est quelqu'un de célèbre
que je raccroche après une chanson tout
le monde dit ça là bas dont je vous dis
bon tout va bien se passer
et donc je monte sur le bateau je vais
dans le salon où est ce qu'on fait c'est
des bateaux avec des pièces il ya des
salons des chambres des cuisines c'est
assez bien organisé et là dans le salon
face à moi elton john et sa famille donc
évidemment je suis en état de choc
parce que je suis fan absolu d'elton
john sauf que moment où j en état de
choc je suis censé commencer mon
spectacle
mais j'ai plus du tout envie de faire de
la magie là j'ai envie tout s'arrête lui
faire apparaître un piano et ça soit lui
qui me fasse un concert et bien je peux
vous jurer que j'ai dû puiser dans des
ressources insoupçonnées pour trouver un
semblant d'illusions de fragments de
confiance en moi et lui dire
ariel tonnes picoguard times que j'étais
là pour ça en fait et le pire c'est que
cette illusion de confiance au fur et à
mesure de ce spectacle est devenu de
plus en plus vrai et ça s'est super bien
passé il ya une autre méthode qui est un
petit peu moins psycho mais qui en fait
quand je suis dans une situation un
petit peu compliqué que je sais pas
comment gérer quelque chose j'aime bien
pensé à des professionnels du métier que
j'admire et me dire comment réagir et
cette personne s'il était à ma place est
très souvent cette personne me trouve
une solution sur le vif comme ça gratos
alors c'est un petit peu comme si
j'avais un conseil de sages à la
disposition de mon imaginaire c'est la
même chose chez soi que vous admirez
plein de gens dans vos métiers
donc je vous conseille vraiment utiliser
d'utiliser cette technique
voilà c'est quasiment tout ce que je
voulais vous dire vous savez comment je
suis devenu magicien d'abord dans ma
tête
puis finalement dans la vie donc s'il
fallait retenir une seule chose je
dirais qu'en en magie on utilise des
techniques pour transformer la réalité
alors j'espère que vous pourrez
transformer la vôtre et réaliser vos
rêves
merci de m'avoir écouté à très bientôt
[Musique]